I hundred or selecting returning officer
for the Chelton parliamentary
constituency declare that the total
number of votes into each of the
candidates as follows for the last three
months Richard Lux and Darnell has quit
his job and spent countless hours
campaigning enough as it up and I'll
workroom out and I don't care he's just
one of more than 150 independent
candidates who tried to go against a big
party system and wish I'd want to
release until the diet not very cool
this with what it was like to go it
alone in the general election give us
your reaction to this exit poll price of
all you Kip hasn't gone any 258 porn
icon labels only you know this yeah yes
um no well now quite because it's
another new experience you know I've
never been to one before so let's go
election night for Richard marks the end
of a campaign of highs and lows the
bookies wrote him off Richard Lutz and
Darnell the independent candidate here
we make him 100 to 1 so again not very
much chance independent very very
different than to break 3 and 6 like
this I'll to swallow I'll just want to
change everything but this chartered tax
advisor wouldn't give up in the way and
soon got himself a column in the local
paper and made a mark with his visible
campaign-style afternoon why I was
Richard and I'm standing as an
independent candidate at some stage he
realized victory was a long shot but
even in the dying hours he remained
hopeful everybody knows I exist
everybody's had something for the
letterbox so yeah and there are people
that I'm hearing about who are advocates
for me out there I'm not awesome they've
just gone to all that makes you need to
hear about this guy so who knows who
knows
however as his opponents piles piled up
high Richard's optimism plummeted let's
cook tomorrow
we're looking at hundreds rather than
thousands so yeah well I God we've had
conversations about what success looks
like and that's just one part of it that
are slightly ever so slightly
disappointed that
I think it's just the crushing reality
of knowing that you might only get a few
hundred votes instead of maybe a couple
of thousand or two or three thousand you
know and it's all more to think about
that but when it actually hits elsewhere
in the country other independence were
getting their results in Salisbury King
Arthur Pendragon got 729 boats in heart
before the campaigning cabby Stephen
picton for almost three thousand declare
right did the best of any independence
coming second in Devon East with well
over 13,000 votes as the boxes of 500
votes stacked up it was clear it wasn't
to be Richards night Alex Shaw
conservative traffic after day 20 4790
Richard John Hobson Darnell independent
270 270 to do you see it as a failure no
I can't was it feel like a failure at
the moment at the moment it feels you
can't help but feel what didn't I do
what could I have done you know I have
to go back and just say there are so
many different measures of success you
won't want to make excuses because
you're not that type of person but has
this process showed you how hard it is
for independence absolutely you know you
are up against it you know you've even
got a guy who's an MP here who was
complaining of you know about about
resource resources yeah it's a Herculean
task required are you going to go back
to being in charge of tax advisor I
don't know that you know it's a blank
sheet of paper when we finally sit down
fighting oh it is hugely exciting but
you know as this has been you know but
we've excitement it comes that not fear
but just the unknown
follow hero